[Music]
tim
amundson you disciple of
robert goulet milton berle elaine may
and rowan atkinson hey tim timmy
timbo welcome back brother welcome back
tim
welcome back i miss you buddy hi
tim that's how we say hi to each other
so
you all are saying that now but anyway
um
welcome home i
really missed you um the first movie and
i am so happy to have my partner back on
the second
wow i am so excited it is so wonderful
to see you back
on the screen with your entire psych
family
oh we always knew that it was never a
matter of if
it was always a matter of when to
welcome you back to the family you this
is sweet how sweet is this
seeing you back here on the screen in
psych two let's do it man
we're happy you're back and we are so
excited to have you back on screen with
us
in the amount of time that we feel we
deserve with you
working with you is a dream you're also
like one of my best friends and i love
you so much
and um i gotta say you
really acted the [ __ ] out of it
we're so excited that this is out there
in the world and that
psych the movie 2 lassie come home
is finally home and streaming on peacock
we're excited for everybody to see it
we're excited for you to be back in
action and for us to see it
again it hasn't been the same without
you
we missed you we need you we have missed
you terribly
welcome back sir love you brother so
welcome back and suck it stroke
you